in the future cuz I guess this was sent
around like 2020 something because they
said this was 50 years in the future and
they were in 19 like 74 future from now
or the future the future from the past
they were like fifty years from now like
when Wolverine comes like he's like I'm
fifty years from now like at least like
Wolverine they like go a little white
hair here yeah that was cool actually I
like that breeze and I'm like Iceman
whatever his name is like oh hey grow a
beard man his older even that was ice
man's coolest [ __ ]
page still looks like she's like 15 the
ice man's coolest moment to me like in
all the x-men was that one part where
he's is flying on the icy creating it
and he's like freezing the Sentinel and
[ __ ] like that was really [ __ ] cool
man we get to see Iceman in his
formative times but this is the first
time you really get to see it was like
this man is an x-man yeah exactly
yeah we're him and Ellen Page together
together it felt like they were they
like kind of like stood next to each
other and looked at they were like
together and I'll say look I look like
they were roads probably dead yeah in
that version of time she probably was a
lot of them are dead but she gave up her
powers so then she's a human so why
would they I mean she's on our side
she was such a little [ __ ] she probably
didn't try to help them use she's like
[ __ ] you guys I'm just gonna go and take
my powers away
I am vampires it's cool you cried have
the power to send people back oh yeah
what the [ __ ] where did that come from
but also like there's an element of time
and space to that then if you're walking
through objects there is time and space
I mean how come that other chick
couldn't do that which other link I
would think Professor X and Jean Grey
could do that because they work with the
mind and [ __ ] this this comes down
to another it's I haven't read this
comic so I don't know what their take is
and I don't know a whole lot about
kiddie I don't think it was kitty pryde
to do something back though I don't know
I think it was Bishop who actually they
also sent back to bishops power he has a
gun and yes to like get charged from
other people's powers I'm not sure
actually I don't really remember this I
mean that's part of the fun of these
movies are going okay so what's this guy
calling all right now I gotta go online
look at me yeah yeah because that cuz
the dude with the like radiation hand I
read about him just now that guy's
called ink and apparently he doesn't
have powers but he goes to this tattoo
artist who can like give you tattoos
that give you powers based on what the
tattoo circle so he gets that tattoo now
so the hearing people if you could
choose any power from a tattoo why would
you choose that one poison that's a good
way to end a fight I'm just saying or
just be like I'm gonna freeze you why
are you like we're gonna get an ice cube
like if you're getting a tattoo I gotta
believe you're gonna at least think
aesthetically as well biohazard symbols
are cool plus I can use this to make
people sick or right away you're not
going to the best the point though is
that if they're vomiting there's no more
fight fight don't fight over they're not
coming back well they can vomit on him
plus plus that would be a good power to
have because it's not readily noticeable
to everyone around if you're shooting
ice out of your hands people are gonna
be like you've got the x-gene and then
if you could like point at people and
then they start getting sick that's
easier to cover up that's easier to not
be noticed doing imagine if he was in a
crowd let's say what if I you just like
make people fall down it's like yeah
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] I want to be able to
throw a banana on the floor any moment
in time like Mario Cart someone's
father's like create ice cream you get
to see a lot of the familiar x-men that
we know and love especially at the end
in little cameos there's a lot of good
Easter eggs yeah like a William Stryker
to like having it
yeah yeah Oh William yeah that's what
you sound like
okay scene where Wolverine starts
freaking out does he realize that that's
Stryker doesn't used to have that flash
front because he sees the like things
and no he knows that that's the thing
you starts getting caught up and you're
like no it's oh I guess like it's Matt
Striker when he was that because he was
like I'm meeting this guy right now at a
point war we haven't met yeah but he
like and he hasn't sung enough that he
looks like that well it's also I mean
that's gotta be sweet creating time I
didn't like I'll take him but it's
really mystique like what's happening
there but then that's also gonna be a
really heavy moment for Wolverine
generally because it's like well oh here
is the young version of the man who's
going to put me through so much pain
yeah but he knows that because he could
obviously just easily kill him but then
he would never get his that mean
compromise the mission which is my
question because mystique is in him in
the end when he's like I'll take him
is she like not how is he gonna get
experimented on in x-men - Stryker and
mystique are obviously establishes two
separate people yeah but they change the
time lineage though in this one yeah so
now we don't know so then I feel like in
the time lineage in the future Wolverine
would not have adamantium maybe
Mystique's like we got a planet in this
guy that is a good question
I love the Easter eggs at the end - when
we see rogue again for like a split
second and then you see see see
no he's these Cyclops and I wish that
means Cyclops could be so much more
awesome yeah in the movies they make him
so lame in the [ __ ] copper comics he
didn't even have to press the button
like he could just go sure the laser
beam Ethan yet and that was so cool cuz
he could do way cooler stuff and he was
buffest [ __ ] do you know he had the
second one he's like barely and there
when he gets killed off like he's a
great actor yeah you know they just but
it's still cool to see him just okay
yeah I think I think it's neat to have
it's like you've got the Easter eggs at
the familiar x-men and then you've also
got some cool other x-men we haven't
seen before you know I thought they did
a nice job mixing the two
I thought Bryan Singer fixed the problem
that x-men 3 created which was we killed
off a [ __ ] on a main characters in the
yeah and he was able to go like hey I
know how to bring them back in at a
reasonable manner so yeah he was like I
can I can make this an x-men movie again
same writer as x-men 3 no way yeah so it
just proves that Brett ran or it could
have been a better director because
there are a lot of story credits on this
movie alright guys so we got some
reasons to see this look there's any
reasons not know I can't think of any I
would say reason to see number one
Quicksilver again love these these the
[ __ ] man heaven Peter's American Horse
or you rock after watching this I love
you
another reason to see Hugh Jackman's ass
done yeah and his performant him
Performance Plus ass and that's what I
would say on Hugh Jackman reason to see
number three right for me as is James
McAvoy good I got to get a stick yeah oh
so far floor would have to be well these
are not really in an order but boomer
would have to be a Michael Fassbender
the remainder
yeah dude he's he was awesome in this
film I thought it was a great antagonist
oh yeah I mean he does it all the time
that he's like like he just brings so
much depth feel like every [ __ ]
moment he's on screen I love him
you see his penis and shame and hunger
yeah we should watch it together yeah
the first time we agree on something
it's just fast-forward to this myth yeah
yeah really creative oh yeah they amped
up the action like they haven't done it
attacks are all great oh yeah visual
effects are awesome whoo the action they
like evolved the the mutant power like
even with familiar characters that are
like we can make it come yeah they
managed to do it in a way that always
feels appropriate which is yes I like
the cinematography a lot on this films
here like cutting back between the
really [ __ ] up future and then
retreating the 70s production design
along with that it's like that's hard to
balance and make it like still seem like
it flows in some way the story itself
the story with the writing and stuff was
incredible very compelling
there was never a moment where I felt
like it was slow or that the movie was
too long it's a very compact like lots
of stuff happens it's weird that's what
I love the Beals compact because so many
things that and the directing to writing
and directing should be like one
category because they manage to take so
many stories and it was the first
excellent movie where I feel like people
are not gonna walk out complaining about
being bombarded yeah as it's not
bombarded and it's a true ensemble piece
it's not Wolverine plus the crowd it's
like Wolverines part of the in samel in
this way Peter Dinklage Oh Peter
Dinklage in turn a killing man he's
awesome Peter dingaling
yes my heater tinkle link yeah that's
his name how what does that mean it just
sounds like a [ __ ] call me wait are
you talking about you just sounds cute
think a link
alright guys check it out a review for
x-men Days of Future past
why don't you comment below and tell us
the most obvious question that I could
have thought of which one's your
favorite x-men movie and once you're
done with that come on over here click
this button so you can see more episodes
of racist
why don't you tell him to subscribe to
your channel subscribe that's Lauren got
channel to the Lauren god I guess idea
but you know it has no videos on it yes
real me she has all her videos from us
if you just want a special Lauren Lyster
Lauren ggaudet of the real rejects yeah
exactly I have one follower and last but
not least if you want get updated every
time a review or videos of ours is out
so skirt click on Lauren's head right
there clickety yeah clickety click click
click dude happen
now I remember back in the day with a
Wolverine claws everyone would like go
in the shadows and take like chopsticks
or some [ __ ] or knives
yeah not the sounding yeah when they
come out they make that sound is that
the noise Jay King King is a person
flash the whole kindness
it's kind of like like skins like it's
really grab not one person like that's
scary there there is a a metallic sound
mixed with the sort of viscera sound
when you're like I'm like this or it
it's like that sandy
I'm sure it's a combination of yes
sounds I don't think it's possible to
replicate with your mouth unless you're
that guy from police academy
mmm-hmm that's true that's true well
thank you guys for watching you say
classy San Diego
I'm Veronica Corningstone I had Ron
Burgundy this is brick you're brick